hi my name is gwendolyn and this is my
daughter jade and i'm teaching her how
to make bunny dip fried chicken so now
i'm making the brine stirring it around
just to make sure that some of the salt
starts to dissolve in the water the
longer the better you know because
grinding just adds more
moisture to your meat and when you fry
it it comes out nice and juicy the
kitchen is my sanctuary like the kitchen
is where i kind of relax and i kind of
aligned you get everything out like you
have those moments with yourself let me
add my own little thing jade ass hot
sauce cooking is always a big part of
most families because it's when you
share stories and you make messes
it's always good to cook the same parts
at the same time so if you're cooking
legs and thighs do all your legs at one
time or do all your thighs at one time
we just want to test to make sure the
oil is hot it's egg wash right right
right little egg wash cleaner the
splatters you're good
i fry once i just wait till it gets nice
and brown
between 10 and 15 minutes on either side
the house that i grew up in we didn't
have a lot of space so we didn't really
come together when my girls were coming
up i kind of changed that
we like had to sit down and eat dinner
together i think it's important to cook
for your families it's an opportunity to
express myself in my food to pour love
into it so that my family can have joy
you know that honey
[Music]
you